MARIA BARTIROMO: Good morning, everyone.
Great to see you this morning.
Thank you for coming out and joining us today
for the CFR meeting.
Welcome to all of you.
Welcome to our members.
This, of course, part of our CEO Speaker Series.
And we've got a really exciting and interesting
morning for you.
Just a couple of notes.
Please turn off all your cell phones -- don't
put it toward "vibrate," because it does impact
the actual transmission -- BlackBerrys, all
of the wireless devices, to avoid any interference
this morning.
We appreciate that.
I'm thrilled to be here with Larry Fink, who,
of course, is one of the great entrepreneurs
and businessmen, financial titans, of our
time.
Larry started BlackRock first when it was
a part of Blackstone.
He then moved -- spun it off into its own
firm and has managed to grow the firm really
extraordinarily, now boasting assets of more
than $3 trillion, the largest asset manager.
So we really (will glean ?) great value from
our discussion with Larry this morning.
So we will have a Q-and-A session.
We'll open it up to all of you.
Of course we have terrific brilliance in the
audience, and we want to hear what's on your
mind, and Larry's excited to take your questions.
But we'll begin with Larry talking to us about
what's going on in the world today.
He of course is the chairman and CEO of Black
Rock.
He leads the company's global executive committee.
He led the firm through its entire two decades,
founded it -- co-founded it.
He was named CEO of the decade by Financial
News in 2011 and has been named one of the
world's best CEOs by Barron's each year -- each
year -- since 2005.
By the way, he is also a member of the board
of trustees of New York University, chair
of the financial affairs committee and a member
of the executive committee, the ad hoc committee
on board governance and committee on trustees.
He is traveling extensively around the world
and has access to the great minds and deep-pocketed
investors globally -- and, again, all the
more reason we want to hear from him this
morning.
So let me introduce Larry to give us his opening
remarks
Ladies and gentlemen, Larry Fink.
(Applause.)
>>LAURENCE D. FINK: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you, Maria, and it's really nice to
be here, especially with one of my mentors
in my career, and that's Pete Peterson, who
has been so influential in the council.
Pete, thank you for all the help.
And much of my success is due to the -- those
few inspirational years I had with Pete at
Black Stone (sic).
I would like to welcome everyone today.
I know it's morning.
We're going to have inclement weather.
So it's -- it's always nice to see such a
hardy audience early in the morning.
So let me talk about my vision of the world
and where I see it.
Let us -- (I'd ?) like to just -- also just
talk about -- it's really -- (audio break
?) -- to be a part of this session, with all
the distinguished guests here today at such
a great, respected forum.
And it couldn't be more important today because
-- and relevant today given how interconnected
the world is and how we are so connected globally.
As daily headlines on European debt makes
abundantly clear, the economic destinies of
people across the globe are inextricably linked.
It is no wonder that for all the record, recent,
hopeful signs of economic recovery and rebounding
markets, there's still a gnawing sense out
there that things are just not right.
Every CEO I talk to -- and I talk to quite
a few worldwide -- are telling me virtually
the same thing: that business is actually
a little better than they planned.
It's -- it actually is starting move to dial.
But they then cautionly say, but things just
don't feel right; they feel, in some respects,
really bad.
So lacking this confidence in the future,
they're continuing to build their cash even
as earnings improve.
And from kitchen tables to trading floors
to street protests in Athens, London or Manhattan,
people are angry, they're frustrated, they're
confused.
They're worried about stagnant incomes and,
of course, eroding savings.
They're worried that government promises of
secured retirement are simply impossible to
meet, and they're looking for leadership,
and they're looking for answers.
Fundamentally a broad crisis of confidence
is paralyzing our ability to make long-term
decisions.
Much of the problem is our inability to look
beyond the latest headlines as they change
minute by minute, with every blog or every
website.
Whether it's about the Greek debt or whether
it's about gasoline prices, in today's wired
world people are bombarded with so much information
and news.
Even if much of the news is good, it's very
hard to interpret the good from the bad.
It's affecting the business decisions from
everyone from the corner office to the corner
drugstore and having a deeply unsettling effect
on the markets with dramatic swings in trading.
It's this shortening time horizon, not just
for investors, but politicians and businessmen
-- this fixation on the short term is also
blinding society to powerful forces to -- in
reshaping the world.
This new world, if you will, is being defined
by three far-reaching and closely intertwined
trends that are disrupting markets, economies
and many sectors of society.
The most -- the most sweeping, yet most overlooked
is the great aging.
According to the United Nations, the over-60
age group will roughly triple in size to 2
billion people in the next four years, growing
more than twice the rate of the rest of the
population.
This worldwide phenomenon is already placing
major strains in the entire global system.
Living longer should be a blessing, but many
older people are now afraid of outliving their
savings.
In the United States alone, the combined underfunding
of Social Security and Medicare over the next
75 years exceeds a shortfall of $40 trillion,
according to the program actuaries.
U.S. pension funds at year end were underfunded
by an average of 33 percent, according to
BlackRock.
Also according to BlackRock, the average defined
contribution plan is underfunded by over 40
percent, so even worse than defined benefit
plan.
And around the world, we're facing an unprecedented
simultaneous withdrawal of both financial
and human capital from the system.
Let's just look at Japan.
It's long had one of the world's highest savings
rates, which helped fund our government and
many other governments' deficits around the
globe.
But it also has one of the world's oldest
populations.
But it also has one of the -- so Japan will
soon shift from a net saver to a net seller
of assets.
This will have a profound impact on the -- on
the world and on government deficits.
Unfortunately, this great aging coincides
with a great deleveraging.
The financial and corporate sector and households
across the developed world continue to reduce
debt and derisk in the wake of the financial
crisis.
It will shape investment, returns and spending
for years to come.
As The New York Times pointed out last week,
anxiety about assuming long-term obligations
is shifting in the United States from a nation
of homeowners to a nation of renters, even
as we witness rising rent prices and affordability
for housing at -- almost at a record level.
And the global deleveraging is being compounded
as governments around the world pursue austerity
plans to address deficit spending.
Governments won't be a source of job growth
going forward, as it has been in -- for many
years in the United States.
So job creation will require a much more meaningful
partnership between government and business.
And further complicating these challenges
is the great migration of the engines of global
growth to the emerging markets.
Over time, this shift of economic opportunity
will help create a more stable world, but
for now it's fueling much more global anxiety.
It's driving global disparity in income on
both ends of that migration.
Those adept at navigating a global economy
have adopted and even benefited while many
others have been left behind.
So we shouldn't be surprised by the social
unrest it caused, whether it's Occupy Wall
Street or the Arab Spring, with its powerful
economic undercurrents.
To sum it all up, we're in a perfect storm
right now: aging population, deleveraging
economies, shifting jobs, income inequality
wrapped up in low growth and low yields -- just
when people need better returns and a better
economic opportunity.
So in the midst of the perfect storm, with
everyone focused on the next change of the
prevailing winds, with confidence so scarce
and volatility so broad, I get asked the same
question wherever I am.
I could be in Abu Dhabi.
I could be in Beijing, Sao Paulo, Zurich or
right here in Manhattan.
The question is simple: What do I do with
my money?
Whether it comes from an individual, a corporation
or a pension fund, my answer is all the same:
You need to get off the sidelines and get
your money working again.
It's the only way individuals can achieve
their financial objectives, the only way corporations
will achieve growth, the only way pension
funds will meet their commitments and the
only way governments can address the great
public policy challenges we face.
Whether it's funding retirement, supporting
education or rebuilding our infrastructure,
all of that is really only doable if we reignite
growth.
So to meet our global challenges in this new
world, we must, at every level, turn savers
into investors.
Worry about the future is driving up short-term
savings.
The FDIC data shows that bank deposits hit
$10 trillion at the -- at year end, up from
$6 trillion in 2004.
They grew three times faster in the first
nine months of 2011 than they did in 2010.
In China, despite strong growth, investors
are keeping far too much of their savings
in short-term deposits, and if this trend
continues, there will be a need from other
sectors to finance growth.
In the same way nonfinancial companies in
the S&P 500 held more than $1 trillion in
cash as of the fourth quarter of last year,
according to Standard & Poor's -- this is
the highest percentage of all assets since
the 1960s -- for CEOs sitting on much cash,
this will ultimately push down their PE ratios.
So what do we do?
How do we get all the money working again?
How do we reignite long-term investment and
growth?
First we must help investors adapt to the
new world.
It's in everyone's interest to bolster confidence
in the long-term investments, but I'll be
the first to say that the asset management
industry has not done a great job in helping
investors take a long-term view.
We have to step up to offer guidance and provide
answers.
To finance longer life spans, we must convince
individuals to start investing now, for the
long term.
But longevity should be an asset that can
be levered, not a curse.
They must understand that there's a cost to
sitting in cash.
No one talks about that cost.
They talk about the cost of volatility, they
talk about the cost of making the wrong short-term
decision, but no one is talking about the
cost of inaction.
We must understand that sitting in the cash,
even in low inflation -- and we need to focus
on that for individuals and for society -- people
unable to afford retirement will continue
to work longer, shifting economic opportunities
for the next generation, pushing unemployment
rates for younger workers even higher than
they are today.
We need to educate investors about conforming
-- confronting the growing gap between needs
and resources for retirement.
In particular, companies have a moral responsibility
to educate their employees.
Shifting from a defined benefit plan to a
defined contribution plan doesn't absolve
them of that responsibility.
That means getting investors beyond a now
inadequate 60-40 portfolio mix of stocks and
bonds.
I personally have said many times I'd be a
hundred percent in equities.
That fits my risk profile and my views of
the world, though obviously it's not appropriate
for everyone.
Most investors need a more diversified portfolio.
But virtually every investor has to find ways
to achieve a better return than they'll get
in cash or government bonds for the foreseeable
future.
Possibilities including looking at new sources
of income, like dividend-paying stocks, higher-yielding
corporate bonds, using both passive and active
strategies, and alternative investments, which
are now becoming more widely available for
individuals.
At the institutional level, we need to help
public and private pension funds face up to
the adjustments necessary to meet their obligations
to their members, such as revisiting outdated,
overrestricted investment guidelines.
The financial community and government can
help -- also help turn savers into investors
by finding consensus on practical regulation
that increases confidence in our markets.
With Basel III, banks will be even more conservative
in their lending, and we'll be even more reliant
on the capital markets in the future.
So it's vital that the financial community
and governments find consensus on practical
regulation that promotes confidence in our
markets.
For example, a new regulation last month by
the CFTC to protect the collateral that customers
proposed -- when searchly -- when centrally
clearing over-the-counter derivatives will
promote greater confidence in these markets.
In the coming months, I also hope that similar
protections will be welcomed for future tradings.
We need financial products and disclosure
that ensure individual investors know what
they are buying, including real risks and
real costs.
We believe, for example, that in the fast-growing
ETF sector, better labeling will boost investor
confidence.
We need a tax structure that encourages long-term
growth, including a capital gains tax regime
that rewards investments over multiple years.
The holding period for an investment to qualify
for long-term capital gains tax treatment
should be extended to three years from the
current 12 months, and the rate should decline
the longer one holds that investment.
Finally, governments too need to take a longer-term
investment perspective.
Just as individuals and institutions should
understand that they cannot count on returns
in one quarter or one year, governments should
consider investments that may not deliver
returns for years.
We need government leaders willing to rise
above partisanship and make forward-looking
investments in crumbling infrastructure and
basic research.
And probably the most important long-term
investment society can make is in education,
an antidote to today's short-term preoccupation,
a means to filter the day's headlines and
see longer-term policies and to adapt to the
competitive demands of the information age,
where even unskilled positions today require
technology competence.
The transformational challenges and the resulting
crisis of confidence that we face as a global
society are daunting.
But we are better-equipped than at any time
in our history to respond.
After all, we possess unparalleled knowledge
and experience, financial and planning tools,
technology and analytics, and we are connected
across the world in ways that were just unimaginable
a very short period ago.
In this new world, we can help build -- rebuild
confidence.
We can rebuild confidence in getting the markets
to moving again, restoring growth and turning
short-term savers into long-term investors.
It is our responsibility as leaders of business,
finance and government.
All of us must come to this -- come to this
answer, and all of us must come to the call
right now.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
>>BARTIROMO: Thanks, Larry.
You made great points in terms of broad issues
that we're all living through and facing.
And before we get into sort of what that means
to us and how to actually approach our financial
lives as a result of the changes that we're
seeing, let's drill down on a couple of those
broad issues that you just mentioned.
And one of them, of course, is the government
deleveraging, governments around the world
deleveraging.
This morning, of course, we did get news from
the European Central Bank that the ECB is
putting forth another lending facility for
the European banks, the LTRO.
Give us your take on the impact of that.
Is this going to make a big difference in
Europe?
>>FINK: In the short run I think it's absolving
much of the problems.
There are many facets that are going on in
Europe.
The crisis that we saw last fall was a liquidity
crisis.
You had the regulators telling banks that
they have to conform to Basel II by this summer,
and then you have the pending Basel III, which
will be out in 2018 when -- (inaudible).
And on top of that, you had failing markets.
Markets were not able to respond.
And actually, it was the banking system that
was selling assets.
And so you had a deterioration of all the
sovereign credits that really jeopardized
the stability of the euro community.
You had yields over 6 percent for Spain and
Italy.
This -- and so it was a liquidity crisis that
we experienced in Europe, not unlike the liquidity
crisis we experienced in the United States.
By providing this liquidity facility, it stabilizes
liquidity, and you're -- you just don't see
the pressure from the banking community selling.
Much of the assets the bank owns are two,
three-year maturity.
So by providing this lending facility, those
banks don't have to sell.
They're going to see those loans slowly roll
off.
And so it does absolve much of the problems
in the short run.
But I think most importantly, by absolving
the liquidity crisis of Europe, it is now
giving the new governments of Greece, the
new governments of Italy, the new governments
of Spain time to fix their political situation
and their economic situation.
So in Italy and Spain specifically, you have
two new governments who have now publicly
stated, we're going to manage our deficits
accordingly; we're going to have these austerity
plans.
That's only part one.
Part two, we need growth.
If we don't have growth in Europe in three
years, this thing all falls apart again.
So it -- this is not a -- this is not a fix.
It's -- but it's a stability to give governments
time to work their problems into a more favorable
position.
>>BARTIROMO: I feel like part of the reason
that individuals as well as corporations have
been sitting on cash is because Europe has
been a wild card.
And we're really not sure how that spills
over onto the United States.
So as a follow-up, are you more comfortable
today that the European upset is less likely
to spiral onto the United States and impact
this economy negatively?
>>FINK: Well, I think for 2012 I think we
are going to see a stable Europe, even with
Greece.
I mean, you know, I would not be surprised
to see some event that may force some change
in the relationship between Greece and Europe.
There may be some evidence of default sometime
in the future.
But I believe that result is going to be less
problematic.
I think -- (inaudible) -- very successful
in stabilizing and firewalling the rest of
Europe, and therefore, if there was that event
-- and I'm not saying there will be, but if
there is that type of event, I think Europe
even will be a more stable place.
So translating that back to our shores, I
don't think Europe is going to be a cause
of concern for our economy.
I think the only cause for our economy would
be if, through these facilities, could we
see a devalued euro.
Now, the euro has actually rallied because
people are less frightened of the future of
Europe, but if we had a euro that was pushed
down to 115, to pick a number, that would
have serious implications for our job growth.
I mean, we benefited mightily as a country
of having a weakened currency.
And so I guess I'm not worried about -- I'm
not worried about failure of Europe in 2012;
I'm worried about success of Europe in 2012
and what does that mean for our shores.
Out 2014, though, if Europe does not find
sources of growth, of economic growth, then
we have a much more serious problem ahead
of us, because, you know, they already did
these lending facilities, and if we still,
after a couple years time, cannot find a mechanism
for GDP growth, then these countries' ability
to -- you know, to afford these deficits become
more problematic.
And so we have two years in front of us to
see if Europe can stabilize its future.
>>BARTIROMO: And under the umbrella of, OK,
what does this mean to me now and what do
I do now with my money, you mentioned longevity.
You know, it seems like every time we discuss
longevity -- I was having a conversation with
someone in health care recently, and he said,
you know, Marie, we're living longer and we
are really facing a crisis.
And I said, whoa, whoa, whoa, stop right there.
We're facing a crisis?
Listen to what you just said.
We're living longer.
This should be a positive, not a crisis.
Why do you point to that as one of the overall
big issues that we face today, longevity?
>>FINK: I think we focus way too much on the
directions of the market every day, and as
I said, people are frightened of, you know,
what that market behavior will do.
And so we're seeing just many people are frozen.
No one is asking the question, what is that
cost of doing nothing?
I don't hear any blog or news station or newspaper
that talks about the cost of doing nothing.
It is enormous a cost.
And if you're a 35- or 40-year-old and still
haven't been preparing for your retirement
in any way, each year goes by, the deficit
or the shortfall that you're going to have
is huge.
And so we are going to live longer.
We have been able to -- lot of science is
-- we've turned a lot of deadly diseases into
chronic diseases.
You know, if you are a couple in fairly good
health in your 60s, the statistical probability,
one of you is going to live to 92 now.
And, you know, you're going to need an enormous
reservoir of savings to achieve the lifestyle
or the standard of living that you're looking
for.
So I think we need to have a call of -- you
know, call to arms right now that we need
to focus on the costs.
And we got to do it at the individual level
so it doesn't become a bigger federal burden
or state burden.
Obviously, it still remains to be a big state
burden, but I think it's a responsibility
for every state fund, every corporate plan
to help educate their workers -- and I mean
part-time workers and full-time workers -- about
what it takes to build the necessary nest
egg.
You're not going to be able to rely totally
on Social Security, and so it's going to have
to be through these private means.
Other countries in the world have adopted
some very sensible retirement plans, and in
those countries they've addressed these issues,
like Chile and Australia, where there are
sensible plans in which people have to save
for retirement.
>>BARTIROMO: Are you surprised that ever since
the U.S. got downgraded, all this money has
gone into Treasuries?
>>FINK: No, because a Treasury is a benchmark,
you know.
So if you think about a swimming pool and
the volume of water in a swimming pool, and
that the Treasury component of a portfolio
represents, let's say, 30 percent of that
volume of water -- and I'm talking about the
volume of water and degrees of risk.
And so we got downgraded, and so definitionally
now that volume of water of risk increased.
So Treasuries went from that 25 percent volume
of water to 30 percent of risk because it
was downgraded.
So you needed to sell other things if you
wanted to keep your risk appetite the same.
And so you didn't have to sell Treasuries.
You -- if you wanted to keep your risk appetite
the same, that means you had to sell other
things, so Treasuries actually did fine.
>>BARTIROMO: Give us your sense of the secular
shifts going on in the global economy right
now.
You're traveling all over the world.
We're hearing a lot about Latin America, particularly
Brazil and the vibrancy there.
We're hearing a lot about, of course, the
growth in China, even if it has slowed down.
What's your sense how significant is the global
slowdown, China having been the engine of
growth for the world?
And what's going on right now in Latin America
or other places you'd like to mention?
>>FINK: Well, I think Latin America experienced
a slowdown in the third quarter.
You saw Brazil going from a 5-ish percent
GDP in the first quarter of last year to zero
and I think in the fourth quarter sort of
turning back up.
But we've seen a slowdown throughout the world.
I don't believe China is slowing down in 2012.
I know I'm in a minority in it.
I personally believe the present leadership
of China have been very successful.
I can't imagine them wanting to hand off the
economy to the new leadership with the economy
in a soft landing or hard landing.
It doesn't seem that -- you know, you're not
going to want to hand off after having such
a great tenure of success.
So I believe you're -- and you're starting
to see evidence of their easing quite a bit
to assure that the economy grows at 8 1/2-plus
(percent) for 2012.
In the last few weeks you've seen governments
encouraging banks to roll over debt, and you've
seen last -- I think it was last week -- the
governments reduce the reserve requirements
in China.
So they're actually easing now to restimulate
the economy.
>>BARTIROMO: So you're worried -- one of your
big concerns is the fact that we are sitting
on such low-interest-bearing money, and we're
not putting our money to work.
How are you putting your money to work, and
what are you hearing from the many deep-pocketed
investors that you're speaking all around
the world in terms of how they're getting
return?
>>FINK: Well, we're seeing some very large
flows.
So we are starting to see some money being
put to work.
This is obviously why we've had this rally
here today where the NASDAQ is up 15 percent,
the S&P is up 9 (percent), most global markets
are up 9 percent.
So you're seeing money starting to be put
to work, and you're seeing the flows are in
areas like high-yield.
You're seeing huge flows, like record flows
into high-yield funds here today.
You're seeing record flows into dividend-oriented
stuff.
So I think investors are starting to look
at these opportunities.
We're seeing -- but overall, there's still
this sense of confusion.
There is still a huge allocation in cash,
huge allocation in bonds.
So I just think on the margin, people are
putting the money to work.
We're seeing a -- we're seeing huge reallocation
into alternatives, which actually gives me
a more constructive view on equities as more
money runs away from equities in some areas
into alternatives.
So I -- it really -- investors worldwide are
asking the same question: What should I do?
And depending on their risk appetite, depending
on their liability needs, you're seeing -- you're
seeing behavior that is -- it's not behavior
that you could say is uniform.
It's individual behavior depending on the
needs of each individual investor.
>>BARTIROMO: So you think that is appropriate
to be looking at dividend payers, to be looking
at these high corporate bonds?
Is that what you believe is appropriate?
>>FINK: Yeah, I mean, if you -- let's talk
about Verizon, a great New York-based company.
It pays a 5.30 (percent) dividend.
Their 10-year debt is 3 1/2 percent, 3 (percent),
3 3/4 (percent).
Even let's talk about a bank that everyone
was worried about only five months ago, Santander,
big in the United States, big in South America,
big in Great Britain and obviously the largest
bank in Spain.
It's paying a 9 percent dividend.
>>BARTIROMO: Do you think that'll stay like
that, 9 percent?
>>FINK: Yeah, I do.
Well, no, it's going to get -- I assume the
stock price will rally, and then dividend
reprice -- the dividend will be less.
But I just think there's some great opportunities
where you can buy stocks that are paying you
a dividend that is far more rewarding than
owning, you know, 10-year U.S. treasuries
at 1.94 (percent).
>>BARTIROMO: I want you to expand on one thing
you said in your -- in your remarks, and that
was about Japan.
You said we're about to see the Japanese become
-- go from net savers to net sellers of assets.
What's the impact?
What are you expecting?
>>FINK: Well, first of all, it's just age,
you know.
It's been a great society of savers.
And over the next 10 years, they're going
to be retiring and they're going to have to
start spending that retirement.
And it's just pure math.
And it -- this should be a wake-up call.
We have time, but it should be a wake-up in
our country about making sure that we are
navigating our deficits.
I think most recent statistics will say that
Japan is the second-largest foreign owner
of our debt.
And it's just pure math that will tell you
that ultimately, these -- this nation of savers
will have to be more -- spending that savings,
and that will reduce their ownership of U.S.
Treasuries.
So -- and so it should just be a long-term
wake-up call, and we should be prepared for
it.
This is not a train wreck.
It will be a train wreck if we don't prepare
for it.
>>BARTIROMO: And amidst all of this, we are
also sort of questioning and debating the
regulatory environment.
>>FINK: Yeah.
>>BARTIROMO: You mentioned in your remarks
the tax structure and some changes that are
needed there.
You mentioned Basel III.
Give us your sense of the regulatory environment,
how it may change.
And do you believe that the current system
is one of the reasons that companies are sitting
on cash and unwilling to pick up the hiring
pace?
>>FINK: Let me answer the latter part first.
I think -- I think most CEOs want to put that
money to work.
They know keeping all that money in cash drags
down earnings.
These are rational men and women who are running
our companies.
They're basically saying, I -- you know, I
know I'm dragging down my earnings by sitting
-- keeping all that money in cash, but I'm
not confident of putting that money to work,
and therefore I'm going to drag down my earnings
with all this money in cash.
We need to find a way -- and it's -- I don't
think it's Basel III, which I'll talk about
-- we need to either -- we need to build that
confidence that spending that money is a better
return on their investment than earning zero,
that spending that money is better for their
careers.
We have to all remember, the average CEO in
America has a term of five years.
And so a lot of times, when you're building
-- doing large capital spending projects,
it's a drag during their tenure, and the results
may not be achieved until someone else's tenure.
So you have to feel very confident that -- spending
that money with a short horizon.
So we -- you know, I didn't say in my speech,
but we should also understand the horizons
of leadership is shortening now too, and -- which
has an impact on how you spend your money.
Basel III is just -- you know, to me, Basel
III is no different than Dodd-Frank.
It is society saying our banking system was
too risky; we need to have buffers so governments
don't have to stand in between the failure
of a bank and society.
There's cost associated with that.
So the men and women who run banks worldwide
-- they're rational people.
Their capital has gone up; therefore their
cost -- their need to make a return on equity
has to go up, because they have more equity
capital.
And so by definition, they're going to have
to charge more for their services.
So that means all of us -- all the pension
funds, all the investors -- we have added
cost.
So the -- so if we don't use our capital markets
and enlarge our capital markets, you know,
the banks are going to charge you more for
their services to make the appropriate return
on equity that shareholders demand.
And that's what -- that's what society wanted
with Basel III.
That's what society wanted with Dodd-Frank.
And so this is -- so for us to reduce those
added costs, we need to have a more fulsome
global capital market, so corporations can
fund and governments can fund and grow.
>>BARTIROMO: Are you expecting the Volcker
rule to be implemented in July?
(Laughter.)
>>FINK: I think some form of the Volcker rule
will be implemented.
I think the Volcker rule has some holes in
it.
We are not in support of it.
We sent the letter as a firm.
It's very hard for me to understand how to
navigate the Volcker rule.
What is proprietary trading?
What is flow trading?
It's going to be very definitional.
But I do believe the Volcker rule gives the
Federal Reserve a lot of latitude.
And so I do believe the Volcker rule will
be effective in July.
We won't know how it's going to be manifested
by the Federal Reserve.
How will they interpret flow trading versus
proprietary?
So if a securities firm, a bank buys a bond
from BlackRock or -- and they can't readily
sell it, but they sell another instrument
to hedge it, definitionally will that be called
flow trading?
Or definitionally will that now be called
proprietary trading -- therefore, it's an
illegal action?
And so it's going to be up to a huge amount
of interpretation.
And this is why it's so confusing, and this
is why I think it's so debatable, because
it's very -- you know, it's very hard to understand
how will the Federal Reserve navigate this.
>>BARTIROMO: And you're -- and you're saying,
look, you need to be active and not passive.
And you need to control your money and make
your money work for you because the forces
around us are still in place, whether it be
this uncertainty around regulation, whether
it be these low-yield environments, whether
it be the pressures from longevity or whatever
else.
So tell us your plan, in terms of navigating
all of these issues?
In straightforward way, what are you doing
as the largest asset manager today?
>>FINK: What I try to tell all our investors
at BlackRock is, one, try to filter out all
the noise.
We are going to have more regulation of some
sort.
We're going to have more uncertainty.
We're going to have issues around Europe or
China.
We're going to have elections in France in
May, which will have a pronounced impact on
where Europe goes.
We're going to have elections here in this
country.
So we have all these different issues.
But inaction is just the wrong decision.
And as I said earlier, the sooner you start
putting that money to work to earn 5, 6, 7
percent returns, the sooner you start navigating
a horizon beyond 10 years for retirement.
You can't focus on the minute.
You can't focus on the noise.
Now, I'm not trying to suggest we could have
-- you know, we may have the market fall back
another -- you know, back to where it was
at the beginning of year, so I'm not trying
to suggest when or where the entry level is.
But the longer you have a view over a long
horizon to meet a target -- and this is really
critical -- the longer you have this view
and a need -- so if earning 5 percent is the
right amount of return you need to get to
your nest egg that you need, it really doesn't
matter, your entry level.
And so I'm trying to get around day trading,
trying to getting around the notion of, when
should I jump in?
The markets are going to move up and down.
>>BARTIROMO: Don't time the market.
>>FINK: Yeah.
And yet, you know, we have, you know, hundreds
and hundreds of people talking about market
timing and when to get in and when to get
out.
And that to me is a noise that we have to
remove.
We have to ask ourself each individually,
each company, what is right for you?
What do you need?
Some person who has a lower standard of living
need may only need a 4 percent return.
I could live with that $1,200 a month of monthly
income.
I could live very successfully.
Another person would say, gosh, I need 3,000
(dollars) a month or 4,000 (dollars) a month.
And so you have to work backwards.
Now, obviously, inflation will erode that
future value, and so you have to add some
type of inflation quotient in there.
But I really do believe we need to start asking
these easier questions about, what do you
believe you need to have the standard of living
you need to?
And stop focusing on the noise.
The noise is confusing.
And in most cases, the noise, in my opinion,
is a healer.
The noise is not -- should not be considered
destabilizing.
The noise, in our democratic society, creates
movement, and most of the time the noise actually
resolve(s) most problems.
>>BARTIROMO: And there's a lot of -- and then
a lot of noise out there.
We're going to open it up to the floor.
We want to hear from our members.
But before I do that, the NASDAQ being up
15 percent and the 9 percent on most major
averages, is that appropriate, in your view,
given the economic backdrop in the United
States?
>>FINK: Well, if you just answer the -- in
the -- if you put it in the context of where
we had in the last two years, it's -- we've
had so much derisking going on that you're
just seeing now people going back into the
market.
Let me just say one last point about why I
think it is appropriate.
Because of the credit crisis, most financial
institutions have shortened up the maturity
of their assets.
Most people don't talk about this.
But at the BlackRock Investment Institute,
we calculated insurance companies to have
$600 billion of purchasing power this year.
That means they have $600 billion of assets
that are rolling over.
I'm not even talking about the banks.
So you add up, just because of shortened duration
of portfolios, and the rollover of insurance
companies, the rollover of banks that need
to put money to work, on top of all the cash
that's sitting in corporations, all the other
cash that's sitting around, you know, I still
believe the marketplaces have a lot more movement
upward.
And also, I believe this answers the question
why rates are staying so low, because the
amount of money that's sitting there is so
enormous.
So if you add up this continuation of deleveraging
that's happening in our country, even with
the federal deficits, we're going to have
$200 billion less outstanding debt as a nation.
Last year we had $300 billion less debt.
So we are seeing this deleveraging happening
as a society at the same -- you know, so at
the private level, we're seeing a huge deleveraging
as the public sector deficits are $1.2 trillion.
So even with this $1.2 trillion deficit, we
are seeing less outstanding debt as a society.
So you factor in the less outstanding debt
as a society, coupled with a short duration
of maturity that banks and insurance companies
-- it doesn't surprise me that we continue
to have low rates.
We're going to continue to have low rates,
which from my perspective gives me a foundation
to believe that equities are going to be a
great place to be.
>>BARTIROMO: Question from the audience.
Dan?
>>QUESTIONER: Good morning, Larry.
Daniel Arbess from Perella Weinberg Partners.
Your observations about investors not achieving
their return hurdles are, of course, of great
concern.
We're in a global debt deleveraging, where
central banks are effectively practicing financial
repression on all kinds of savers, pushing
people into riskier assets.
My question follows Maria's last question,
which is, the notion that you can get a higher
return on equities is an interesting notion,
but we all know that equities are much riskier,
as well.
So the environment that we're in, characterized
by a lot of contentiousness around austerity,
taxation, et cetera, et cetera, is not really
conducive to robust economic growth.
At what point do you say equity valuations
are going to be stretched so that there's
as much risk as there is potential enhancement
and return going into the asset class?
>>FINK: So I would argue that, you know, equities,
despite this rally, are unchanged in 10 years.
We have P/E ratios that are hovering around
in the 12s.
You know, we had equity markets hovering around
the 12s in 1980, too.
We had 10-year Treasuries at 9 and 10 percent,
and now we have 10-year Treasuries at 2 percent.
I think we have a long ways to go to make
equities look expensive.
And I do believe our corporations are in unbelievable
shape.
Their balance sheets have never been stronger,
certainly a lot stronger today than they were
in 1980, certainly their ability to navigate
with low interest rates really allows them
to do things they would never have been able
to do.
And so at this time, looking at long-term
valuations, I think equities are the place
to be.
Now, that's my personal view.
And, you know, I believe you're paid to own
equities, especially when you incorporate
not only the P/E ratios but the dividend returns
that you're getting in equities.
>>BARTIROMO: And that is always U.S. equities?
Are you more poised to put money in the U.S.
right now or outside the U.S.?
>>FINK: I would say what I personally like
the most is buying multinational companies
that are less dependent on one country.
I like multinational companies.
They may have 40 to 60 percent of their engines
of growth in the United States, but I do like
the diversification of being more global.
>>BARTIROMO: We've got a caller coming in,
national member, Ben Wolf from Celfin Capital,
in Santiago, Chile, right now, asking: You
mentioned the success of the Chilean privatized
pension fund system, which has not only provided
an excellent retirement system but has also
contributed significantly to the development
of mature and deep capital markets, which
in turn fuel growth.
Do you think there is any prospect that the
U.S. or any other advanced economy adopts
a similar system either in whole or in part
in the medium term?
>>FINK: I hope so.
I think as we -- I said earlier, if you look
at Chile or Australia, they're going to have
a pool of resources to provide the capital
to build infrastructure, to build -- to build
these countries.
You know, when we tried to do that I think
three, four years ago, they called it -- when
I think Secretary Paulson was talking about
the privatization of Social Security, that's
basically what they were trying to do, creating
a mechanism in which investors had choice.
In Australia, you have the superannuation
funds in which you either -- you have eight
or nine options how to invest, and you choose
how to invest.
But it's a government requirement for part-time
and full-time to withhold 12 percent of their
disposable income.
Now, if we did this in this country, we'd
go -- we could go right into a recession.
You know, and so there's -- there has to be
this balance of how much money are you putting
away, and how much money are you -- are you
using for consumption.
So it's not an easy thing to go from a nation
that is probably only putting, you know, 6
(percent) or 7 percent away, which is inadequate
right now, where you really don't control
it in the DB side.
On the DC side, you have choice.
But you know, as I said, in these other countries,
you have fewer choices to go into -- you know,
different structures that help the individuals.
I've seen in Australia how it's been done.
The individuals are actually -- see if you
save this much money, here's what you're going
to be having at the end of the -- and you
know, when you retire; this is how much money
you could have at 65 or 68 or 70.
And it gives -- it gives you a lot more clarity.
>>BARTIROMO: Well, it's sort of mapping it
out, mapping out the plan.
Yes, right there.
>>QUESTIONER: I'm Susan Davis.
I lead a nonprofit organization called BRAC.
And I was intrigued by your perspective or
call to arms for us to take a longer-term
perspective, investing in infrastructure and
education.
And I wondered, is there a -- in looking at
equities, what's your firm's perspective on
impact investing?
And in the context of this systemic failure,
do you look at equities or companies -- business
as usual, or are you factoring in the climate
change crisis, global poverty, the tensions
that are causing the Arab Spring and other
factors?
>>FINK: (Chuckles.)
Yes.
(Laughter.)
No -- all these social issues are -- you know,
are very difficult to navigate.
Depending on each individual company, you
have to -- you have to pay attention to these
issues.
There's no question that we all have a responsibility.
We have a responsibility to our country.
We have a responsibility to certainly our
employees.
We have a responsibility to our community
and to -- and navigating those issues are
difficult.
The pressures of earnings is one that's very
hard for a lot of companies.
But getting back to me as an investor or how
we -- as BlackRock as an investor in terms
of how we look at these things, we look at
impact investing; we look at social issues
as a very important component, especially
as we think about proxy voting.
You know, we just sent out a letter under
my -- under my name to 600 companies worldwide
about proxy season.
And as a shareholder, we are taking a much
more -- interest in how companies perform.
And we believe it is our fiduciary responsibility
to take an active view, especially in light
of so much of our assets are indexed money.
We have to own these companies.
Whether we like them or not, whether we think
they're doing the right thing or not, we have
to own them.
And so therefore the only power we have is
our vote.
And we're spending a great time now -- which
I'm not involved in; I can't be involved at
all.
We have a special committee that is involved
in terms of making those decisions on issues
that you brought up and how that impacts our
voting.
And what we wanted to do through this letter,
to tell all our companies that we invest our
monies with, our clients' money with, that
our vote is going to be important, and we
are not going to allow our votes to be influenced
by proxy voting services, which I do believe
-- too many investors rely on proxy voting
services and not spend enough time on taking
their own responsibility of voting on behalf
of their investors.
So I don't have a straightforward answer,
but I can tell you we are taking a pretty
deliberate view on these social issues, and
we will express that one by one in the proxy
voting season.
>>BARTIROMO: And one of the priorities that
you've been mentioning this morning is a return
to growth, reigniting growth, but we walk
such a balance in terms of reigniting growth
and putting austerity in place, even in the
United States.
How worried are you about the $14 trillion
debt in the United States?
Should we be prioritizing cutting back, putting
austerity in more so than we are?
Or is putting enough stimulus out there to
reignite growth really the preferred priority?
>>FINK: Well, that's the big debate today,
about how much stimulus we need to re-engage
this economy.
Of course we worry about the $14 trillion
of debt, and the debt's growing a trillion-plus
(dollars) this coming year and probably another
trillion dollars next year.
So we have not -- you know, despite all this
noise, we have not addressed our deficits
at all as a country.
We -- you know, there's been very little in
terms of bipartisanship in terms of navigating
these deficits, and that's going to be a priority
for 2013.
>>BARTIROMO: Can the U.S. turn into Italy?
>>FINK: No, because Italy actually has more
savings than us -- (chuckles) -- plus the
--
(Laughter.)
>>BARTIROMO: But I mean, you're talking about
120 percent debt to GDP -- I mean, everybody's
trying to make a comparison --
>>FINK: Yeah, from -- but they actually have
so much savings there that, you know, the
difference between -- you know, the difference
between Italy and the United States -- 80,
90 percent -- I don't know the exact statistic,
but a high percentage of Italian government
debt is held by Italians.
We don't have that problem.
We have -- as I said, we have Japanese and
Chinese and a lot of foreigners owning our
debt.
And so, you know, we have -- we have a problem.
As I said, it's not a train wreck problem.
It's not something happening now.
It's a problem that you could actually, you
know, look out and --
>>BARTIROMO: A plan --
>>FINK: -- if you don't address this in the
next few years, it's going to be a hole that
is going to be very hard to navigate.
>>BARTIROMO: Jacob Frenkel.
>>QUESTIONER: (Audio break) -- thank you.
Jacob Frenkel, JPMorgan.
You described the global deleveraging like
-- as the major -- as one of the major dangers
that we have.
And indeed governments all over the world
have tried to mitigate the consequence of
the global deleverage of the private sector
by creating excess leverage of their own books,
and that's the budget deficits and the debt,
and central banks have expanded their balance
sheet in an unreasonable way.
So question number one: Is it obvious that
excess leverage of the public sector is better
than the excess leverage of the private sector,
which it is supposed to replace?
And the second question related to it is,
given the extraordinary low interest rate,
which you spoke -- as a challenge to private
investor, is there also a big challenge to
the macroeconomy of negative real rates?
Do we plant the seeds of the bubbles and the
next inflation?
>>FINK: I don't see any -- let me go from
the back first, Jacob.
I don't see any risk of inflation for the
next few years.
Until we start seeing some real growth in
employment in Europe and the United States
and more stable, growing economies, I don't
think we're going to have that much inflation.
Now we may have spiked inflation if there's
any crisis in the Middle East related to oil
and things like that.
But I'm not -- and I do believe our central
banks have time to navigate a change of policy
if there was any (whiff/width ?) of employment,
which would translate into an increase in
inflation.
So I don't see an inflation bubble in the
next one or two, three years.
I think there is time for that.
(Audio break) -- one can argue -- (audio break)
-- we had proper regulation, having the leverage
in the private sector is probably more sensible,
because we have shareholders who attack it
every moment, whereby it's very hard to attack
government.
And so one can argue having this increase
in deficits in the public sector is more difficult
to navigate, outwardly.
On the other hand, there is a role of the
public sector to try to stimulate economies
and to try to create a(n) environment where
our economies can grow.
So I believe it's a balancing between the
public sector and the private sector.
Now, obviously, you're correct in saying all
the growth in the deficits are in the public
sector, whether it is in the balance sheets
of a government or in their Federal Reserves
or central banks.
I do believe there is -- we have time to navigate
those risks if it's done sensibly.
But I do believe we need to really make sure
that we are -- that we have a system in which
we don't have crises like we had in 2008 and
2009.
But I don't think we understand the cost of
those mechanisms.
And so I do believe we're all going to have
to be living in a future with a more regulated
approach.
And if we don't develop our capital markets
-- not just here in the United States, but
if Asia doesn't develop their capital markets,
their problems will be just as severe as our
problems in the future.
>>BARTIROMO: We want to have one more question.
I -- all the way in the back, right over there.
We want to keep everybody on time, so briefly
want -- actually it was the person in the
back.
MS.
: Very back.
>>BARTIROMO: Sorry.
>>QUESTIONER: I'm Rob Dieterich from Bloomberg
Markets Magazine.
I just want -- earlier you said -- you made
a direct connection between the current crisis
of confidence or lack of confidence and our
inability to make long-term decisions and
sort of long-term thinking, I believe you
were saying.
But I want to sort of challenge that or ask
what the connection you're making is.
If you look back to, say, circa 2007, when
I think we probably arguably had an excess
of confidence in the system, I don't think
we were making long-term investment -- (inaudible)
-- decisions at that point either.
So what's the connection you're trying to
make between the current crisis of confidence
and our inabilities or our problems right
now to make long-term thinking?
>>FINK: Well, I think -- in 2007, we had certainly
over -- we had -- we had confidence that was
obviously, as you said, way over our (skis
?). We had -- we believed that leverage is
not a pernicious problem in society.
So that overconfidence was that we believed,
you know, a couple dozen men and women could
navigate credit risk in 30- and 40-1 (leverage
?).
Unfortunately they were wrong, and regulators
were there too.
So it's not like -- and shareholders were
there too, I mean, nothing was not -- let
me restate that: Reporters were there too.
So -- (laughter) -- we were all guilty of
overconfident that we could navigate that
type of risk.
But I think it's the backlash -- the other
side of that problem is the -- is the causal
lack of confidence today.
I think, you know, we could look back today
and say, how on earth did we think a firm
can navigate 30- or 40- or 50-1 leverage?
And we have regulators saying how on earth
have we -- did we not, you know, protect society
better?
And so we are -- we have moved the pendulum
way too far the other way.
And I think now in an era of low-interest
rates to navigate, you know, our way out of
this problem, hopefully through low-interest
rates, we do stabilize the situation, but
most importantly I think we haven't changed
our behavior.
Because of the fears of the precipice of the
result of '08 and '09, I think people are
just standing there, mostly (uninvested ?), sitting
in (too ?) large of low-yielding instruments
and they're not addressing their longer-term
issue and that is, what do I do with my money?
How do I prepare for my future the same way
I prepare for my health future, (right ?) ? There's
just too much commentary, maybe not enough
on your health, but there's no commentary
about how to have a standard of living that
meets your future needs.
>>BARTIROMO: So barring people just hearing
what you're saying and saying, OK, look, I
need to make a change in my own financial
life, do you see -- as we wrap up here, do
you see a catalyst on the horizon that will
trigger growth, reignite growth, reignite
that money moving into -- and to make it work
for us?
For example, will the election in November
be a catalyst for the economy?
>>FINK: That's a long ways away.
In -- I think we're starting -- you know,
I think if we continue to see stability in
financial markets, I think on the margin,
you're going to see a behavior change.
And through that change of behavior, you're
going to -- you will see some form of job
growth.
You're starting to see that now.
You're starting to see, on the margin, an
improvement in jobs.
We have to remember 2011 we experienced 30,000
fewer jobs per month on average because state
and local governments cutting back.
And so much of the problems last year of anemic
job growth was the public sector -- of paring
down their payrolls.
>>BARTIROMO: Is that still going on?
>>FINK: Well, we have -- we will still have
those pressures.
That is why I said in my speech we need to
have this partnership between government and
the private sector.
If we are going to have above-trendline growth,
it's not going to come from the public sector.
It's going to come from the private sector.
You know, we've lived in a -- in a nation
in which the public sector has grown in jobs.
The public sector, as we saw in 2011, started
shrinking those jobs.
That will continue, and so we need to find
-- you know, we need to have a more vibrant
private sector to continue to build jobs.
You know, I could go on in many other ways
that we -- I think we could do that, whether
it's -- you know, there's a proposal for tax
regime changes, which I don't wish to get
into.
But among those things are ways to stimulate
job growth.
>>BARTIROMO: And these will be catalysts,
then?
>>FINK: Yes.
>>BARTIROMO: Yeah.
Extraordinary that we're actually seeing,
by the way, leadership change possibly in
France coming up, in China, potentially in
the United States --
>>FINK: Germany next -- early next year.
>>BARTIROMO: Germany as well.
So really a world leadership change.
Larry, thank you so much.
Thank, everyone.
>>FINK: Thanks, Maria.
Thank you.